[موسيقى]
أجنبية لن أعرف أبدًا
ما الذي جعلها
مثيرة للغاية
في حين أن قلبي أخذ
الحياة في الحال
يا
[موسيقى]
لذا أولاً وقبل كل شيء تهانينا ،
هذا حلم تحقق
للجميع لذا أنت نصف  مصري
ونصف أمريكي نعم هل تتحدثين العربية
[ضحك
] لبعض الأشياء
مرحباً
[موسيقى]
نعم ، لقد جاء والدي إلى هنا في الثمانينيات من
الإسكندرية مصر
وأراد
أن تعرف أن تخلق حياة جديدة لنا هنا
في الولايات المتحدة وقد التقى  أمي التي تدرس اللغة
الإنجليزية كلغة ثانية وهذه هي
الطريقة التي التقوا بها ، لقد علمته حرفياً اللغة
الإنجليزية ، لذا
أقصد ثم بدأت في ممارسة
الفنون وأحب حقًا أحب
رواية القصص وفي الواقع
كانت سيدتي الجميلة واحدة من أولى العروض
التي  لقد شاهدت من قبل مع أودري
هيبورن وريكس هاريسون ووقعت في الحب للتو
وكان هذا هو التاريخ
[موسيقى]
لذا أخبرنا عن المشاعر التي لديك
قبل دقائق من بدء أدائك
يا إلهي ، فأنت تعلم أنها هدية إنها
هدية حقيقية  لتكون قادرة على ص  erform
والأداء هنا في los angeles
في dolby حيث توجد جوائز الأوسكار
وبعد 18 شهرًا الأخيرة من معرفتك
بالصمت وإظهار الأعمال التجارية التي يتم
إغلاقها تمامًا ، إنها حقًا هدية
لإعادة الاتصال بالفنون وأن تكون
في غرفة مرة أخرى مع  جمهور
واستمع إلى التصفيق والتواصل معهم
واحصل على تلك اللحظات ، إنها حقًا
قصة ليزا الخاصة تدور حول الطموح
والحلم والتغلب على
التحديات التي
أمامك والعقبات التي أمامك وهي قصة إنها
قصة إنسانية
يمكن لأي شخص أن يرويها  لمحاولة تحسين
حياتك بشكل صحيح وهذه هي بالضبط
قصة إليزا ، لذا فأنا مرتبط بها كثيرًا
خاصة بعد الـ 18 شهرًا الماضية
لأعرف أن هناك أملًا وهناك
ضوء في نهاية
النفق لم أستطع النوم في رأسي  خفيف
جدًا لمحاولة ضبطه
يا
[موسيقى]
أنا فخور جدًا بأن أكون جزءًا من
الجمهور الذي يشاهد شيرين وهو يعيد تأدية
الدور المذهل لفرس النهر الأكبر سنًا
وتشويكار كما فعلنا
نحن فعلناه ،
إنه دورنا
لكن من المدهش أن يكون لديك مصري
يلعب دور البطولة في مسرحية إنتاجية شهيرة من برودواي في وسط
هوليوود وهو يتجول في
المسرح
حيث تُصنع الأوسكار ، لكن
هذه الهالات
تشبه
المستوى الأخير للبلاي ستيشن إذا كان
لديك أي فكرة عما أنا عليه.  أتحدث عن
[موسيقى]
صحيح
[موسيقى] ما
هو شعورك حيال كونك أول
ممثلة من أصل عربي ، نعم تلعب
مثل هذه الأيقونية كيف تشعر
أنها مذهلة.
المجتمع وهكذا أنا آخذ ذلك
مع الكثير من
الدروس والدروس التي تعلمتها وهي فقط
خاصة جدًا ، نعم ، ما الذي نغني به ،
هيا ،
لا ، لا ، اذهب ، اذهب ،
لا أعرف ، شكرًا لك على إراحي من
سرير سيدتي اللطيفة لم أستطع الذهاب إلى السرير ، كان رأسي
خفيفًا جدًا لمحاولة ضبطه
للنوم ، ولم أستطع النوم الليلة
[موسيقى]
رائع ،
كيف تشعر عندما ترى
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى  ]
رافي ليس لديه ما يفعله  مع هذا فقط أنا ،
حسنًا ،
أعني أنني رأيت للتو مشاركة أفضل
أداء على الإطلاق وأنت تعرف
ما الذي ستصبح نجمًا كما تعلم كيف
مع قليل من الحظ